I'm tempted to say smart creative people
have no particularly different set of
character traits than the rest of us
except for being smart and creative and
those being character traits and then on
the other hand I wrote a biography of
Richard Fineman and a biography of Isaac
Newton now there are two great
scientific geniuses whose characters
were in some superficial ways completely
different Isaac Newton was solitary
anti-social
I think unpleasant bitter fought with
his friends as much as with his enemies
Richard Fineman was gregarious funny a
great dancer loved women
Isaac Newton I believe never had sex
Richard Fineman I believe had plenty so
you can't generalize there on the other
hand they were both as I tried to get in
their heads understand their minds the
the nature of their genius I sort of
felt I was seeing things that they had
in common and and they were things that
had to do with alumnus Newton was much
more obviously alone than Fineman but
Fineman didn't particularly work well
with others he was known as a great
teacher but he wasn't a great teacher I
don't think one-on-one I think he was a
great lecturer I think it was a great
communicator but when it came time to
make the great discoveries of science he
was alone in his head and now I'm
talking to when I say he I mean both
Fineman and Newton and this applies also
I think to the the geniuses that I write
about in the information Charles Babbage
Alan Turing ADA Byron they all had the
ability to concentrate with a sort of
intensity that
is hard for mortals like me to grasp a
kind of passion for abstraction that
doesn't lend itself to easy
communication I don't think